مع مرور عام على اعلان بوتين اعتراف بلاده
باستقلال دنيتك ولو كان الانفصاليتين في
اوكرانيا لا تزال المعارك على الارض لم
تحسم يبدو ان احد اهداف بوتين للحرب لا
يزال معلقا بعد فشل السيطره على المنطقه
لم يتوقف الامر عند هذا الحد حيث يظهر في
الخلفيه خلافا او خلافا بين القاده او بدا
واضح بين القاده العسكريين الروس ومجموعه
فاغنر المدعومه من بوتين والتي تقود
المعارك في شرق البلاد منذ اشهر بوتين
الذي اعلن في سبتمبر الماضي رسميا ضمن
لوجان سكودونيسك بالاضافه الى زابوريجيا
وخرسون قال ان سكان هذه المناطق اصبحوا
مواطني روسيا والى الابد مع ذلك الاوضاع
على الارض افسدت او افسدت ولو مؤقتا خطط
السيد الكريم الرميه لبسط السيطره على
المناطق الاربعه مدينه كذلك الواقعه في
دنيتك مثلا وهي اكثر جبهات القتال اشتعالا
حيث تقع اشتباكات ضاريه بينما تسعى موسكو
الى احراز اول انتصار رئيسي لها في
الميدان منذ صيف 2022
باتت ضخمه رمزا للمقاومات الاوكرانيه اما
على الجانب الاخر يبدو انها تكتكات الحرب
ليست فقط وراء عدم تقدم فاغنر فبالنسبه
لقائدها يافجيني بريجوزين ارجع ذلك الى
وجود مشكله كبيره كما قال في امدادات
الذخيره لقواته وسط خلاف عام مع عقده
الجيش بريجوزين هاجم وزير الدفاع الروسي
ورئيس الاركان وقال انهما يحاولان حرمان
قواته من الضخائر واصفا ذلك بالخيانه
يصدر رئيس الاركان ووزير الدفاع امرا بعد
امر يمنع تقديم الذخيره لفاجنر ومساعدتها
في النقل الجوي جاءت المعلومات للتو تفيد
بانهم رفضوا حتى امدادنا بمجارف حتى لا
يتمكن الرجال من الحفر هناك ببساطه معارضه
مباشره ومستمره وهي ليست سوى محاوله
لتدمير فاغنر يمكن ان يقارن هذا بالخيانه
العظمى الان عندما تقاتل فاغنر من اجل
باخموت وتفقد المئات من مقاتليها كل يوم